what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for Zack Snyder's Rebel Moon one of his
biggest passion projects finally being
brought to life which was originally
pitched to be a Star Wars project but
now it's just gonna be his own precious
Trilogy baby John how are you for at
least the Snyder Awards yes that is what
is happening right now ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead leave a like
on this video and it's a Netflix trailer
they don't
we got an ad let's run that ad thank you
to our marvelous sponsors Amazon and
scopely because we're going to be
talking about Marvel strike force today
people yeah look at the background now
I've done my time in the trenches with
this game look at this raw footage let
me tell you it's as addictive as Tony
Stark's caffeine habit you'll feel like
Doctor Strange bending reality
assembling a mix of your favorite Marvel
characters into one unbeatable Squad in
my lineup I've got the PowerHouse Luke
Cage the web slinging Spider-Man the
Relentless Punisher the deadly Elektra
and the ever essential most underrated
Shield Nick my latest recruit crossbones
wouldn't have seen all the symbiosis of
their powers in the 5v5 battles it's
like watching The Avengers assembling
all over again a personal MVP obviously
Spider-Man because let's face it with
great power comes a whole lot of
butt kicking I thought I would rhyme but
didn't Marvel Strike Force isn't just
about the thrill of the battle no it's a
game of chess with an Infinity Gauntlet
I see what I did a tough level is your
Thanos and figuring out the right
character upgrades and skills to rely on
is your end game and listen up Webheads
with an Android make your move through
the Amazon app store it's like finding a
tesseract
of deals you get 20 off in-app purchases
for Marvel Strike Force and Amazon coins
some more bang for your buck assemble
your ultimate Squad unlock characters
like the regenerating degenerative
Deadpool the enigmatic Venom the
Star-Spangled Captain America The Genius
billionaire playboy flat the rest of
Iron Man hey don't forget the shield
medic and many more and stand as Earth's
Mightiest Defenders click on the link in
the description box to download Marvel
Strikeforce from the Amazon App Store
and type head first to no action under
Roost
[Music]
oh man he's got his composer back
do you know the story of the princess
Issa no
wow in myth she was called the Redeemer
so illustrious said this child would
stop the madness of War wow
that she was too Usher in a new age of
peace and compassion that's Anthony
Hopkins oh yeah
the world I will never
give that bird
glove for a child
I could not see this feels
like pure Innovation man oh yeah
so freaking Epic
what do you think they want
everything I found her
that screen Corey stole
I am child of War
it's taught that love is weakness this
feels like Zack Snyder incarnate oh yeah
this is left to his own devices
yes
Sif look at this price to pay for your
defiance
Wowie
damn
one moment
I do love this part
hold on anime epic sci-fi all
encompassed in one
is that a Charlie Hunter too yep
creature designs and the Aesthetics are
amazing
first man Buckbeak
it's also like a Pure Fantasy look at
this man oh yeah it's got a little bit
of everything he's done so far and more
oh yeah I know that's all the
combinations and a man can fail
remember
also got that uh
Insurrection Uprising yeah Rebellion
yeah baby
die for what you believe
he also was a cinematographer for this
movie
okay yeah all right Army of the Dead
this is his
when they say Visionary director Zack
Snyder this is truly a visionary
child of fire on the scar Giver oh my
God
oh yeah and he also yeah it's had this
project in mind for like 20 years sure
20 minutes ago good yeah I mean in a way
this almost looks like a like a sucker
punch 2.0 not in spirit not in direct
aesthetic but in the way that it's just
like everything Zack Snyder crammed into
one movie except you know post all the
DC experiences now you know yeah yeah
um
that looks beautiful that looks better
than most movies that are coming to the
movie theaters
that's a trailer man like nothing like a
Zack Snyder trailer yeah I haven't seen
Sucker Punch but I get what you're
getting it yeah you'll see that trailer
and you're like this is just all this
stuff that's the only Zack Snyder film I
I have yet to catch um so you've seen
the elves uh that is the uh there's two
Zack Snyder movies I have yet to catch
well we'll play a new reaction before
this comes out when we are riding that
SEO train come December 20th 23. uh but
yeah I thought this was an absolutely
beautiful trailer you can see the Star
Wars Inspirations the the the pieces of
history that he absolutely adores also
his like obsession with uh human anatomy
as well but also the different creature
designs and the the wonderful Ensemble
that is here Tom hulkenberg I believe is
is that his name txl yeah he he who did
the you know he was a composer for of
course Zack Snyder's Justice League uh
and then some Army of the dead as well
and now he's back here this is a this is
like a pure passion project brought to
life and even though I said part one and
part two I believe that this is supposed
to be a Trilogy as well and also
expanding this universe into being a
graphic novel on top of that game yeah
and the video game as well so there's so
much that they they want to do here and
you you can see it all here on display
like like I said during the reaction
this feels very Innovative uh just it's
pure like marvelous creativity at its
finest you know yeah and it looks like
it has a little bit of everything like
it's got all that scopic sci-fi stuff
but it also looks like you are going to
spend a good amount of time just like in
the slums of this world too and just
looking at it seems like he's drawn a
whole set of societies and stuff like
that and I think that's a fun thing to
do because we've seen him tackle so many
expansive graphic novels that already
exist and now this is him kind of
putting all of his interests again not
unlike what I imagine a sucker punch to
be but this feels like so much more
thought out and mapped out it's like
it's got elements of the Rings it's got
elements of gladiator it's got elements
of a million Sci-Fi movies you could
think of and even though I'm sure it'll
Center on a particular group of
characters it looks like or a particular
character it looks like you've got kind
of a ripley-esque lead as a through line
but you also have this massive Ensemble
and there's so many different design
flourishes and yet they at least as of
this trailer feel like they all kind of
coalesce into one world that I could see
how it was Star Wars but it doesn't feel
like it was just scrapped for parts and
quickly repurposed you know it doesn't
feel like the remnants of something that
was clearly that but it does feel
certainly inspired by that kind of thing
and yet it also has the Zack Snyder Edge
where it like this feels a bit more dark
and heavy and harrowing than what I
Associate's my word oh I'm so sorry the
duplicitousness
The Dread of this world
it's kind of boisterous and it's energy
a little bit it was a matter of working
into the Earth
trailer
feels a bit edgier than uh you know a
lot of what we've seen out of a Star
Wars so it feels like you're still
getting that gritty you know like the
same way his comic book films are sort
of adult it feels similar to the Star
Wars it's like it's an adult version I
mean people often chalk up Zack Snyder's
work to something that in the most
implicit terms of being very dark and
this actually provided you know I could
see how this was once a Star Wars pitch
because this is all about you know
fighting oppression it's called Rebel
moon for crying out loud and it's space
it's Space Opera so yeah it makes a lot
of sense and uh but you do get that that
quality especially Anthony Hopkins
narration of like darkness and coming
into the light and the fighting for
what's right I love everything that I
saw here it's really hard to criticize
anything honestly especially knowing
that it's going to be a part one and
part two and as we all know Zack
Snyder's work tends to work better the
longer the film is you know like if this
was only one movie then I might be like
ah it might get a little undercut it
might be a bit underserved you know even
I really enjoyed Army of the Dead uh but
I still felt like I still have some a
little bit more room to grow especially
in terms of like the storytelling
Department you know I still really liked
it but there there were elements that I
thought could have been better fleshed
out but knowing this is a they're going
to be releases a part one and a part two
like okay that's the way to do it then
especially when you're dealing with Zack
Snyder's uh voice you know if it was
much latitude as you can now all we can
hope for is that by the time December
rolls around that uh everyone involved
with the writing and then the acting uh
they get their their rifle residuals and
then they get paid fairly for this and I
believe that this was I I could be wrong
you can correct me I think this was done
for under a hundred million dollars part
one wow like I I think of that I I would
believe it only because of the amount of
things he's shot in like his backyard
that you wouldn't be able to tell he
just seems like he's so got the second
hand second like nature of the
filmmaking that yeah he probably knows
how to make something look great and
also come in slightly under budget yeah
the artistic merits here are are
absolutely excellent I I guess that the
the only thing that can have me a bit
worried is just some other things that I
might have had with some of like I I
love a lot of his films and then there's
a lot of things that I I also share some
of the same opinions on of okay we'll
get too caught up in the visual
experience but he communicates a lot via
tone and mood and atmosphere
but I I guess I'm like well if you're
going to be a part one and part two uh
we really we're gonna be meeting new
characters so we really gotta get
severely emotionally invested in them if
we're going to be on board for this very
epic long journey and uh yeah so it's
not really a criticism of what was shown
here it's not even a criticism it's just
a bit of a of a concern yeah so we'll
we'll see you know like uh I just I just
care about that first and foremost
before anything else honestly because I
love all that stuff but before anything
else I care first and foremost of I
gotta be on board for what they're
fighting against and the motivations and
all the goals and stuff rather than just
generality of good versus bad I gotta
attach to these characters yeah and I
can't be too Bleak or too over rod It's
gotta also have some Spirit of fun all
right guys so what did you think of the
Rebel Moon trailer did you love the look
of it are you excited for it be sure to
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when uh we will of
course we'll be reacting to it why the
hell not gee it's the one movie we're
gonna skip uh now we're gonna definitely
be reacting to it and so keep a look out
for a reaction when this comes out in
December thank you guys so much for
being here
[Music]